E
FA CANTI.
CLAIMED THAT JEWISH AMERICDO  BK
NOT LIKE OR CARE ABOUT
SPOTHETH
NO
LET'GEHAE FORMESNATHAN
GREENBLAT.
SC
FOR PEOPLE W
ANTI-SEMITISM, LET'S PLATHEM.
CHRISTIANSOVE THANTHUNTRY THAT
THE JE COUNTRY.
D THAT ISRAEL HA POWER
DA EXACT
OPPOSITE.
YOU LOOK AORK
HATES ISRAEL.HATE.
SHAT"
.
IN 45 R FIVE ANTOP
PERHAPS
JEWS IAMERICR
SOMEWHLY ATTACHED TO
IS.
60% SATHY HAVE AR INSRAELI
OR THE  ONEEN ERY S FORMEPRESID
WITHEWANDCHILDREN  OF THENI
GET STUFF LIKE THIS GH ATALKING
UT WIDESPREAITIVE FEELINGS
E  COMMUNITY FOR
THJEND YOU POINT OUT OF .OPES A,
LOYALTY, CLANNISHNESS, LIKLLY,
O GO SAID, ISRAEL,
GOING TO QUOTEELERCONGRESS AND
THE EXT ABRESS
OR ABSOLUTE POWER OVER CONGRESS,
TH TANTISEMITISM
YOU HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE
CLAN.
>> THAT'RIGHT.
THIS SOUND LIKEN
OR THIS SOUND LIKE SOME OF AL P
HE.ISRAOE HAVE ABSOLUTE
POWER OVER ANYTHING, EVEN ITS R.
LAYS INTO THESE
STPES, JAKE, THAT
HAVE LED TO JEWISH PEOPLE BEIN
, SUFFERING FROM
KIS NOT SOMETHINWE
TAKEN
'S FME
CHIEF.
IT'
BDISTURL
CHRISTIANS LOVEL MORY A LOT OF E
RIRT
ASBEHINDHA
WHAT IS HE A
LS, CATHOLICS, OTHER
S TH OTTAOF
LATTER DAYAIL VERY
UT THESTATOF ISR BE
SRAEL MORE SAY
OU
LIKE THAT'S THE KIAL
'T BECSET
THE BOTTOM LINE,AK
ANTI-SIT THESETROPES AND MMORE H
STATE, HELPS N
RTEWISH PEOPLE.
>> MEAN, ALSO YOU DON''S C
HE SEEMSBE -E
TO LOOK AS
LIKEPOOR
ASW MUCHE
ME, FORUMP.
OVERWHELMILYD ME
SO, EFY LOVE ISRAEL
MORE THAN JE WHO
DID NOT VOTEOR
AS ALWAYS IS H EGORDSTICK
DETERMINE ME  MEASURE THAT HO
, SOMEONE'S ZIONISM.
BUT NONE OF IT W.E HAVE SEEN TI
S LE T
ORGANIZAS ST
MOVEMENTS, EMPLOY THE SAME
MYTHS, JAKE, AND U IT
JUSTIFY THAND
UTION PEOPLE.WRG.
, HE WT AFTER "THE
CLNEWSPA IS
RUN BY JEWS.
HE GOES ON TTA TS WHE PAPER FOR.
BUT STORK
TIMES" IE SAYSIS
"THE NEW YORK TES
THIS T AINTO
COLLE MEDIWE
KNOW THE MHSJEWSCONTROLLIN WALL
REVALLEY, YOU
ITS CO
PATHOLOGIES HED ITS ANIT SHAPESK
PUSHING OUT UDICE.
HAT WE HAVE HERETHE BOTTOM LLLE
MYTHSKE, THEY
ENTHEY DON'TITH OUR
.